ce père de famille a deux enfants
atteints du handicap de l'ataxie de
friedrich cette maladie
neurodégénérative n'a pas été détectée
tout de suite ce qui a posé des
problèmes dans la scolarité de leur
enfant au début l'histoire a commencé
avec des anomalies en dise dyspraxie il
ya une espèce de d'errance diagnostic au
début des discussions parce que le don
ça commençait avec antoine qui était en
6e des discussions avec les archives du
collège
finalement ses deux enfants ont pu
passer leur scolarité dans des classes
dites ordinaires christian braillard un
peu plus tôt dans la journée à évoquer
toutes ces difficultés notamment le non
remboursement des fauteuils de ses
enfants auprès de la ministre en charge
du handicap
celle ci s'est rendu ensuite dans les
yvelines d'abord dans une unité
d'enseignement externalisés dans l'école
des mesnuls cette classe prend en charge
des enfants ayant différents troubles
ici à une vraie politique d'écolo clusif
c'est à dire qu'il ya une classe pour
enfants et qui ont des troubles
autistiques et des troubles de
comportement des troubles des fonctions
cognitives totalement inclus dans cette
classe ici avec une volonté du maire des
élus ici présents de l'éducation
nationale de l' agence régionale de
santé de l'association des tout petits
qui gère justement cet accompagnement de
faire une réalité de cette école
inclusive dans cette classe seulement
six élèves et l'enseignant t présente
seulement à mi temps l'objectif ici est
donc d'ouvrir une seconde classe la
prise en charge des élèves atteints d'un
handicap se fait jusqu'au lycée sophie
cluzel s'est donc rendu ensuite au lycée
jean monnet à la queue-lez-yvelines dans
une classe qui accueille des enfants en
situation de handicap
l'équipe éducative a pu expliquer ce
qu'est la mise en place pour le bien
être des élèves on a des aides en
situation de handicap qui font partie du
lulisme unité localisée pour l'inclusion
scolaire ses élèves
viennent en cours et son
sont dans leur classe 2
dans leur classe de classes classiques
ils viennent nous a lu lice pour revoir
les cours pour préparer les cours selon
la ministre en charge du handicap cent
mille enfants handicapés de plus sont
scolarisés depuis quatre ans